We're going to start by looking at how
to convert just one clause from CNF to
3-CNF.
This is going to be the heart of
the argument because we're going to
be able to apply this procedure to each
clause of the formula independently.
So consider this one clause
consisting of literals Z1 through ZK.
We're going to have three cases
depending on the number of
literals in each clause.
Note that I have left off K equals
3 since nothing needs to be done in
that case.
When there are two
literals in the clause,
the situation is easier to understand.
We just need to boost up
the number of literals to three.
To do this we include
a single extra variable and
trade in the clause z1 or
z2 for these two clauses here.
One with the literal y1, and
one with the literal y1 nod.
If in a truth assignment,
z1 or z2 is satisfied,
then clearly both these have to be true.
On the other hand, taking a satisfying
assignment from these clauses here,
the Y literal has to be false
in one of these two clauses.
And so therefore z1 or z2 must be true.
We can play the same trick
when there's just one literal,
z1 in the original clauses.
This time we need to introduce two new
variables which we'll call y1 and y2.
Then we replace the original
clause with these four.
Note that if z1 is true, then all four
of these clauses are true as well.
On the other hand, for any given
truth assignment for z1, y1 and
y2, that satisfies these four clauses,
the y literals
have to both be false in one of these
and that then implies that z1 is true.
Lastly we have the case where
K is greater than three.
Here we introduce K minus
three variables and
use them to break up the clauses
according to this pattern.
Let's illustrate this
idea with an example.
Consider this sixth literal clause here.
Looking at this, we might wish that
we could have a single variable
that captured whether any of these
first four literals were true.
Let's call this variable y3.
Then we can express this overall clause
with just three of the literals,
y3, or z5 or z6.
At first I said that we wanted y3 to
be equal to z1 or z2 or z3 or z4.
But actually it's efficient and
considerably less trouble for
y3 just to imply the truth
of one of those literals.
This idea is easy to
express as a clause.
Either y3 is false, in which case
the implication doesn't apply, or
one of z1 through z4 better be true.
Together, these two clauses
imply the first one.
If y3 is true,
then y3 bar is false, and so
one of the z1 through z4 must be true,
and so must the original clause.
On the other hand,
if y3 is false, then z5 or
z6 must be true, and so
must the original clause.
Also, if the original
clause is satisfied,
then we can set Y3 equal to
the disjunction of z1 through z4,
and these two clauses will
be satisfied as well.
Note that we went from having
a longest clause length of six
to having one of length 5 and
another of length 3.
We can apply this strategy again
to the clause that's too long,
by introducing another variable y2.
And trade this long clause in for
a shorter clause,
this time one of length 4 and
one of length 3.
Of course we can play this trick again.
And eventually we have just three
literal clauses, this example is for
k equals 6 but an inductive argument
will show that the argument works for
any k greater than 3.